is he gone
I don't know
he got very short of breath and he was
hurting and
I think he went
succession surprises fans with the death
of a major character just three episodes
into its final season when I read the
script I found it shocking and
emotionally devastating it felt like the
most exciting episode we'd shot because
it moves in real time it was just like
game over you don't have to act major
spoiler ahead if you haven't watched it
all happens on Conor Roy's wedding day
when his father Logan played by Brian
Cox unexpectedly dies on his private jet
to Sweden as you know my father Logan
Roy was pronounced Dead on Arrival
at Teterboro Airport this afternoon are
you satisfied with the way that things
were wrapped up for the road yeah yeah
I'm absolutely delighted so how did we
get there well the episode starts with
the Roy patriarch doing business as
usual with his son Roman hey pop hey
Sean
I've started over and I really think you
should come and see the sweet you get
inside this oh okay uh yeah yeah yeah
you know the only thing is um Khan's
wedding once Logan boards the plane
there's a medical emergency which
happens off screen who's there Tom
what's going on what happened he was
short of breath and he went into the
bathroom
and he was going and there was uh
someone heard something and he was uh we
were concerned
if they went in they broke in then the
Roy siblings Kendall shiv and Roman are
hit with the news their father is in
fact dead so what we do today will
always be what we did the day our father
died
so let you know let's
grieve and whatever but
not do anything that restricts our
future freedom of movement we didn't
really have a death scene for Logan and
that was obviously intentional we wanted
to capture a of death that people
experience in the modern era of
separation of communication over phone
and email it's a brilliantly observant
show of our time as for why Logan's
death may come as a surprise Well turns
out Brian continued to show up to set
the actor tells deadline he was at
Logan's funeral to quote throw people
off scent I'm happy that it's in a good
way I'm happy it's over
but there's one moment Brian wasn't
present for Logan's actual death scene
yeah that's apparently not him he says
quote I was never there they decided
Well they didn't want to do that I think
it's a phone and an ear we've got to the
point where the show it's reached its
natural closure I think our show is
perfect and neat in the way it is my
brothers and I just want to say that
Logan Roy built a great American family
company
and as you know
the board will be convening in the next
hours to decide on the leadership of the
company going forward as for who Logan's
successor will be well there are seven
episodes left for fans to find out and
Roman himself Kieran Colgan promises E.T
the show goes in a different direction
from here on out we don't just want to
see people crying and then have a
funeral and be done with the show we
want to see how a death of someone's
significant rebounds around a family
foreign